AFTERNOON. AFTERNOON NOW WE
WILL CALL THIS MEETING TO
ORDER- AND WE ARE GOING TO BE
HEARING ONE ITEM TODAY ON
CONSENT SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL TO SEE IF WE HAVE A
QUORUM. HERE HERE MATHIS.
MATHIS HERE AGUIAR-CURRY YEAR
AND YEAR PERIOD HERE CUNNINGHAM
CUNNINGHAM HERE FLORA FLORA
HERE GRAY ARE WHEN THEY'RE
IRWIN HERE JONES SAWYER LEVINE
ROBERT RIVAS ROBERT RIVAS HERE
SALAS. WE HAVE A CORN SO IF WE
COULD HAVE A MOTION WE HAVE ONE
ITEM TODAY THAT'S ON CONSENT.
ALL RIGHT THE BILL HAS BEEN
MOVED AND SECONDED SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ON AB
TWELVE BY THE MOTIONS TO PASS
TO APPROACH RECOMMEND. EGGMAN
HI THE NINE MATHIS HI MATHIS
SIGNED AGUIAR-CURRY FIVE A YEAR
HI CUNNINGHAM. CUNNINGHAM I.
FLORA FLORA AYE GRAY- WENT.
IRWIN AYE JONES SAWYER LEVINE
ROBERT RIVAS. HI RIGHT RIVAS I
FOUND. THAT BILL IS OUT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR SEEING. WE
WILL LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN FOR
FIFTEEN MINUTES FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS. TO CORRECTION THE
FIRST DAY BACK- WE'LL LEAVE
THAT ROLE OPEN FOR FIVE MINUTES
FOR ABSENT MEMBERS WE
APPRECIATE THE MEMBERS WHO GOT
HERE ON TIME WE LOOK FORWARD TO
THE REST OF THE YEAR BEING. AS
EXPEDIENT THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
YEAH OKAY WILL LIFT THE CALL I
DON'T SAWYER I. YEAH LONG. WE
LIKE FLOWERS. ALRIGHT I THINK A
PERSON
. THERE'S A FOR THE
CONSENT CALENDAR MISTER GRAY. I
THINK IT WAS GREAT
. MR LEVINE
HI MISTER MISTER LEVINE HI.
THANK YOU RESTORING
. MR SALAS
ON THE CONSENT ITEM. I CELLS
AYE THANK YOU VERY MUCH MEMBERS
THIS CONCLUDES OUR HEARING